المتطوعون الطبيون الإماراتيون،
المتطوعون الطبيون الإماراتيون الذين ذهبنا معهم
إلى المستشفى الميداني، ولكن حتى
في تلك النافذة القصيرة، شعرت حقًا
بالفظائع المطلقة التي
تحدث في غزة،
كان هذا المستشفى مليئًا بأصغر
ضحايا هذا  أطفال الحرب
المشوهين الذين يرتدون جبيرة كاملة والمغطين
بالحروق 2 ثلث
الضحايا كانوا من النساء والأطفال
ورأينا بالتأكيد أن المولودين في
هذا المستشفى كان هناك غارة بعد
دقائق فقط من وصولنا بالقرب من
المستشفى أه اثنين  جلبت الإصابات
صبيًا يبلغ من العمر 13 عامًا فقد نصف
ساقه، ورجلًا أكبر سنًا آه مع قدمه
تتدلى، لذا كان الأمر
مروعًا، وكانت تجربة مروعة وواقعية للغاية
لمعرفة مدى صعوبة
الحياة على الأرض،
لذا أولاً  من بين كل ذلك، يجب أن أقول غيل
إن الأشرار الحقيقيين بصراحة هم
الصحفيون في غزة الذين يفعلون ذلك
والذين يقتلون ويصابون كل
يوم، والأطباء الذين يقيمون
في هذه المستشفيات التي تتعرض
للقصف حيث يوجد
انهيار كامل و  استمروا في عدم النوم
مع القليل من الدعم للقيام بكل ما في
وسعهم لمحاولة مساعدة شعبهم لقد
استمتعنا بمكانة مميزة للغاية في
هذه المناسبة شعرنا
بالأمان نسبيًا كنا على الأرض لمدة
ساعات فقط ولكن كمراسل حربي
التي تقوم بذلك منذ ما
يقرب من 20 عامًا، وخاصة
كأم، فأنت لم تعتاد أبدًا على رؤية
الأطفال الذين تم تقليدهم
وتشويههم والذين فقدوا
عائلاتهم بأكملها، تحدثنا إلى عمة طفل يبلغ من
العمر 18 شهرًا يُدعى أمير والذي  لا
يعرف حتى الآن أن والديه وإخوته
قُتلوا في غارة
تركته محطمًا حرفيًا،
وهو أمر ليس من السهل
معالجته على الإطلاق، ويمكنني أن أقول بصراحة أنني
لا أعتقد أننا رأيناه من قبل  إنه على
هذا النطاق تماماً أه كما نراه
يحدث على الأرض في غزة الآن